welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and spider-man no way home rewrote
the rules of the mcu and the
spider-verse in all kinds of ways
spoiler warning if you haven't seen the
film yet but one of the most curious
surprises was the way peter parker's
spider sense works now exactly in
addition to some cinematically tense
depictions of peter's dread more than
we've seen in the mcu yet when doctor
strange pushes peter's astral soul from
his physical body peter continues to
instinctively move that box away from
strange's grasp totally bewildering the
sorcerer how does peter do that could he
always do that what changed let's break
down the full history of peter parker's
spider sense and really get inside of
peter's tingle i'm not crazy about that
freezing and if you're also curious
about this entanglement you gotta check
out our new limited edition strange
entanglement shirt that you can get at
newrockstarsmerch.com okay spider-man
spider-sense is a classic component to
his power set the ability to psychically
detect danger moments before it comes
allowing him to evade and duck attacks
annoying the crap out of his bigger and
more powerful foes the toby maguire era
of spider-man depicted it via sam
raimi's macro photography in peter's
fight with flash and in the final act of
that movie when he sensed green goblin's
glider and evaded it last second
oh
the mcu reboot of peter parker at first
focused less on peter's spider sense he
demonstrated some sharp reflexes
catching the wet fluid in civil war and
he had a similar glider move while
fighting the vulture in homecoming then
infinity war showed the hairs on peter's
arms standing up when he sent danger in
the beginning of the movie and then at
the end of the film peter sensed his own
dusting moments earlier than everyone
else i don't feel so good
you're all right i don't i don't know
what's happening but then far from home
gave peter's spider sense more weight to
the story
so sorry
i thought that you could sense that with
your
peter tingle so what's up you can dodge
bullets but not bananas i need a break
see after the trauma of getting snapped
and then blipped back something the mcu
explores again from the perspective of
monica rambo and elena bolova peter had
numbed his spider sense so he failed to
see mysterio as a threat until he was
able to regain the tingle while fighting
the drones blind on tower bridge and
stopping a mysterio who was invisible to
him from shooting him in the head but
now spider-man no way home puts peter's
spider sense in the forefront director
john watts uses recurring dolly zoom
shots with a similar horror sting sound
effect first when peter senses doc ock
and then again when green goblin arrives
really the most chilling spider-sense
sequence is in happy hogan's condo as
peter senses osborne's betrayal and then
mei's death and then in the final battle
all three spider-men simultaneously
sensed the coming threat at the statue
of liberty this whole evolution was to
give us a bigger context to the super
mysterious depiction of peter's
spider-sense when doctor strange pushes
peter's astral soul from his body and
despite his detachment peter's physical
body continues to dodge strange one step
ahead of him and you can actually see
some wavy lines shooting out from
peter's head in the astral dimension
just like the way spider sense is
depicted in the comics this confuses
even peter who has never been in the
astral dimension before this but he says
this feels amazing which is not the kind
of euphoric rush that strange or bruce
banner felt when they were in their
astral forms and also unlike their first
times peter's soul can swim back to his
physical body this novice skill that
peter shows here is honestly a bit
closer to wanda maximov's mastery with
astral projection and the wanda vision
post-credits scene where she's able to
split her consciousness to search the
darkhold at the same time her physical
self is brewing some tea this tells us
something new about peter's spider sense
that it is actually fed by a kind of
magic that comes from the multiverse i
know i know spiderman no way home just
gave us the perfect holiday gift and i
think we need a way to celebrate the
magnitude of this occasion well our
merch partners at epic hero are stepping
up to release the biggest shirts of the
year not like in size but you know and
like they're a big deal i'm very
important my apartment smells of rich
mahogany they have multiple new shirt
designs inspired by no way home strange
entanglement is the newest member of
their limited edition latest obsession
line it looks so cool they also have a
new spider polo the special successor to
their mega hit loki gator polo it's a
perfect gift for the nerd who likes to
break up the t-shirt rotation with an
occasional collared shirt you know it
gives it gives some structure to this
undefined unknown region but there's
also a sick sinister six shirt in the
style of the usual suspects movie poster
and of course way more spidey merch on
the way really they have all kinds of
shirts and hoodies and stickers other
merch inspired by loki
other properties including a new kingpin
inspired shirt long live the king
celebrating wilson fisk's return to the
mcu in hawkeye and of course there's
also official new rockstars merch with
our logo some cases with my name if you
ever see me in public and you're wearing
one of these i am legally required to
high-five you so what you gotta do is
sign up for their newsletter at the
bottom of their website to get notified
about the latest merch drops and check
out all of their incredible products at
epicheroshop.com be your own hero
peter's multiverse fueled spider sense
was established in recent marvel comics
in spider-verse number one by jed mckay
miles morales learns that his spider
sense is actually called arachno
frequency and it comes from the web of
life and destiny the cosmic force that
connects all spider entities across time
and space in the spider verse it's what
gives all spider heroes their
instinctive perception of their worlds
and oncoming threats now i don't know if
the live-action mcu or sony films will
actually ever use the term arachno
frequency since lately they seem
reluctant to even call it spider-sense
though the upcoming animated spider-man
across the spider-verse may feel more
comfortable with a comic bookie lexicon
either way this explains the new
functionality in no way home it is
because of peter's alternate reality
selves toby maguire peter andrew
garfield peter have crossed into this
reality due to the magic of doctor
strange's spell and cross the wires with
tom holland peter's unique spider sense
that heightened it in a way that
amplified his soul in the astral
dimension in this moment like various
nodes of a spider web interlocking with
each other the more nodes there are the
more powerful they all are collectively
this also explains the uncanny link
among the three peters throughout the
film the way they complete each other's
sentences yeah you know the way they
serve as empaths for each other's grief
the way they actually feel at each
other's physical pain like with toby's
tense back and when andrew knows toby's
pain from goblin stab wound and when
goblin swipes tom holland peter from
catching mj andrew garfield peter
instinctively is right there thanks to
his sharpened and amplified arachno
frequency that he shares with his
brother but the question that remains is
how much toby and andrew were already
aware of this multiverse magic because
they both seemed a bit thrown by their
crossovers yeah andrew started babbling
about string theory ned and mj did find
them a day after they had adjusted to
being in a new reality but andrew and
toby the moment they see each other
immediately whip attack each other
before they realize that they can
actually trust each other as if both of
them had been attacked by variant peters
in the past also andrew asks magic's
reel here 2 which is an interesting line
considering in his two films that
fantastical elements were very much
grounded in sci-fi and engineering and
then when they see doctor strange rather
than marveling at a freaking wizard they
both berate the guy for visiting the
grand canyon now sure this could be just
some amusing banter that's common among
ncu final battles but i bring it up
because in toby's continuity there is an
alternate doctor strange in that
universe according to j jonah jameson in
spider-man 2 in 2004. what are we going
to call this guy dr octopus that's crap
science squid crap doctor strange that's
pretty good
but it's taken now these used to just be
jokey references that we could shrug off
but no longer spiderman no way home
deliberately ties in specific dialogue
specific production design oddities from
the past eras now as official multiverse
canon no way home invited us to
speculate on the lives these two peters
lived after we left them in 2007 and in
2014 and things like magic the
multiverse and a spider sense that
connects all peters as well as miles
morales and gwen stacy is something that
we are about to explore a lot more and
you can celebrate this new era with our
new strange entanglement shirt and
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter eaboss follow new
rockstars subscribe to rockstars for
more analysis of everything marvel
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you